think that In the Heat of passion that
men would take a more logical approach
to birth control if it became their
responsibility no this is what I was
saying before that men were not logical
in that moment no I do not believe that
men are their thinking logically okay at
all I
I I disagree I think men go are you
invested are you on anything but you
want anything but okay but remember we
spoke before about like oh women have
more power and like you know your body
and blah blah are men really gonna be
like are you ovulating right now like
when like is this no but they don't say
that they definitely say oh you want
anything are you taking it but not
necessarily means they've got to you
know but even if you say no are they
gonna be like oh no oh yeah it's true
yeah so that really like they may act
like they're being logical but yeah
they're just are they really if we ask
you and you say no
what more can we do yeah
don't do it don't do it that wasn't what
she asked you she said In the Heat of
passion if your man had couldn't if a
man why are you asking if the outcome is
the same you're still gonna do a what's
the point of that well you could offer
after pill right
what about what about the guys what do
you guys think
I've been thinking about it um
you're the flashback
I think if if you're in the Heat of the
Moment
and you know I was responsible
but are you responsible oh would I be
responsible like
sorry what was the question
okay do you think do you think In the
Heat of passion that men would take a
more logical approach to birth control
if it became their responsibility
yeah so going back to it I think In the
Heat of the Moment
I think most men
would slip
because yeah as in like most men will
not
um take accountability because
you know how it is you know
um
how is it yeah can you explain
I think In the Heat of the Moment I
think you would just want to like keep
going you know
um if you then had to take
responsibility I think stopping at that
point in time
would be difficult
I'm just
I guess I'm just talking for myself here
but
um
what if what if if it was like a male
birth control
do you think more men would be
responsible I think if there was I I
personally if I had to take it I would
take it because I know the implications
of if I didn't take it and the lady was
to get pregnant
you know
and I have to pay child support and do
all these other things I think I'll be
extremely responsible because
[Music]
um
um there's so much at risk which I don't
really want to have to maybe provide for
someone that I'm not really
um it depends on the relationship you
know if you're in a long-term committed
relationship then that's different but
if you're in a if it isn't a
relationship like that then I think uh
yeah I wouldn't take any risk but then I
find even if it's they're not in the
relationship men still take that they
don't take that precaution
so whether your contraception's there or
not men are still doing the same
craziness a lot of men don't I think I
personally would okay yeah I personally
would okay what do you think yeah with a
question about In the Heat of the In the
Heat of fashion so
crazy I'm just throw the spanner into
the whole thing
um
I'd probably go where he said like a lot
of men would uh lose it
um you know knowing in that moment and
saying oh no I'm not back control
they're probably just oh just lay slide
and stuff so yeah I think
um yeah yeah I love my Lego and what
what about birth control you think if
men had to take birth control would they
be more responsible oh yeah yeah yeah
okay absolutely they'll like they'll
take it every more if you have to take
it every twice a day they will be on
that stuff
because it gives you that more sort of
like an added protection right yeah
because maybe women don't do that much
because abortion is available what if
you had abortion available would you
still be on it or you're like I got
plumpy
would make
because that's the only option the you
know the pill no I would still be on it
I wouldn't want to go through a process
where I have to take out a baby like oh
my baby so I'll sleep you on it
like 100 I'll be on it like crazy
because maybe a lot of women they don't
take ritually because there's there's so
many options after Pearl abortion but
again I'm
I'm answering these questions based on
the fact that I do not know how pet
control affect women so I don't know you
don't I can only hear from you you know
what I mean I just see as a former
conception or a tablet you can take but
I don't know how it affects your
hormones and stuff so based on that I
don't know I'm just saying based on what
I know I'll just take it all the time
but then if it makes me crazy every now
and again I might not so yeah
what do you guys think
uh
I think men would take more of a logical
approach
um
because I'm thinking about just take me
for example if
firstly if I am doing a bareback it
would be for someone that I could see
myself
um having a kid with if not then I
naturally would strap up now if I was
made aware so me personally I'll be I'll
first find out before I even have sex
with a person if they own anything
that's me I can't feel for everyone in
the heat in the moment huh In the Heat
of the Moment I would because if I know
you say it
let's look like this yeah
it's I've so me personally it's either
I'm going to put the strap on First and
she might be like oh no it's fine I'm
all right
sorry sorry
no but this is me I naturally put a
condom on
straight away I don't think twice but
I've been told a couple of times I
didn't need to because they were on
something so I'm saying well oh if I
wasn't going to I'm first going to ask
if I need to right now I reckon there's
a lot of men that would ask
been awesome and I wouldn't ask
but I I still feel like if the
so in regards to I still feel like if
that was the case and you are because
even the case of I remember someone's
saying about if
you asking and she said she isn't and
you're gonna ejaculate anyway I don't
feel like you're going to get to that
stage before you even asking you more
likely will ask beforehand because if
you if there is a risk you can get
pregnant you're not really going to want
to ejaculate inside anyway that's what
I'm saying so that's why I feel like it
in
and also
um this is one of the terms we hear a
lot in um media about digmatized for
example there's there are some men that
if you're really good at it you can even
change the way the woman's thinking
you can change the way the woman
speaking Canada so
in that respect
yeah I just feel like for that first in
that initial view I feel like as men
maybe not all men my father asked men if
we could
make a logical decision at that moment
we I feel like we would make a lot of
men would make sure but there are some
men that could also using Federation
there's a lot of people that drink and
talk that have sex intoxicated so your
brain even thinking right so I'm saying
if you're both intoxicated then you
probably won't have that question
because
it is what it is in it but then it's
both decisions then yeah and in regards
to if would men take birth control I
think we would because then it more
likely eliminates that risk there so you
ain't got to worry about oh if I do
close you're gonna get pregnant because
you know she won't so you have to as men
you'd have more freedom yeah you'll be
like okay cool I know my birth control
she ain't gonna get pregnant I ain't
gonna work but I was gonna make sure no
diseases and I ain't got none I'm saying
so I recommend we'll take it because it
eliminates us from having to be told
take accountability be responsible yeah
we did we took birth control don't come
to me no more I'm saying so that's my
point on that I'm thinking um
if men was taking birth control it'd
probably make more men more Reckless
because yeah
you're not gonna have my baby anyway so
like 100 but obviously it's a dangerous
game
um and in terms of you saying
um
will men be more responsible if
I forgot what you said
would men be more responsible if uh
logical approach to not logical problems
do you think In the Heat of the passion
that men would take a more logical
approach to birth control if it became
their responsibility and yeah we would
take more responsible I just think
because we don't really think too
emotional
um along the lines when it comes down to
having
having sex and if we know we're going to
get something out of it
um knowing that yeah she might she's
going to get pregnant then men will
probably put their foot down and be a
bit more serious about the situation
um
if that if the rules were reversed I
would assume I'm curious from that as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible